anything I got to do in
treport
no okay N Get Out jeez that was the
[__] mayor all
right okay I guess I'll get out I me I
drove here 6 hours from Birmingham so uh
good run all right
um
okay
stay I'm I'm staying a block
away what's Boer
[Music]
is that a town okay I guess it's town
all right I didn't know if that was gay
code or something you
know I thought that guy was hitting off
I'll be staying in Boer and Boer is my
[__]
so I'll see you
there all right I'll check out
Boer thank you sir I guess we'll go to a
casino looks they said the Horseshoe is
the good one it's in Boer oh is it in
Boer sorry you're obsessed with
Boer I've only been there once and it
was to [__] your wife but other than
that okay I'm joking sir we're having
too much fun here all
right big country what's that big
country Big Country don't go to sick
country
uh-oh this is like a Twitter com comment
section go oh all
right big country Big Country okay no
not a big country uh-oh okay all right
this is turning into a town hall meeting
here all right everybody relax we're not
going to go to Big
Country all right jeez Louise sir this
guyy this guy's a big [__] all
um okay no big country I assume there's
a mechanical bull there all right there
you go
cool I can't get on those I'll I'll have
a miscarriage
yeah that's going to feel pretty good
for a lady though huh hitting that right
area huh it's really just a big old
vibrator you're riding you
know now how you now you know how it
feels only last 8
seconds
ladies
okay all right what else is did I catch
everything in the news what else is
going on
George Santos he's out there yeah George
Santos or as I call him political Smet
yeah that guy's got more identities than
the lgbtq you know yeah he said his mom
was in the Holocaust his dad was in 9/11
and he want to be like two neither of
those events even happen so come
on just kidding sorry
Jews look at that Louisiana Jews that's
rare yes sir yeah what you got a
crawfish on that yamaka what's going
on there a lot of shellfish in this
state I don't know how you do
it and thanks for coming out on the
Sabbath I appreciate that and also
Shalom and sorry about Christmas um we
really shove that in you guys' faces but
uh you got the Hanukkah
candles what you got there
sir all right he got deported
okay thought I heard something for a
second you guys [__] in the
house is this a
riddle two guys [__] in the house oh
in the Senate all right so you got to
elaborate a little Jesus
Christ I don't know what the hell that
means and the s on the CATE floor good
Lord could you be more
[Applause]
vague you guys [__] in the
[Music]
house I don't if you're a public speaker
sir good yeah the two guys [__] in
the house I saw the video that was wild
they did it twice apparently uh Jesus
Christ yeah that's crazy um it's a hot
video I mean you're gay you liked it
right
the house Speaker lives here the house
Speaker lives
here oh wow is he here L is
she a boy Mike Johnson Mike
Johnson lives in boy this guy loves
Boer
Jesus all right so that about Boer
you're like a [__]
brochure
a brour all right um
okay DLS Cavaliers yes I went to dsell
did you go
there did we
[Music]
[Applause]
[__] all
right all
right just like the sex I got no respon
resp okay yeah I did I was the mascot of
my high school for one game and then
they fired me cuz I got too drunk and I
did a bunch of
this they weren't having IT Crowd loved
it but uh
yeah anything else topic wise Jeffrey
epin Jeffrey Epstein okay well I've been
to the
island I was 14 I got to meet Bill Gates
ah worst summer job I ever
[Music]
had oh yeah that list might come out
they're checking it twice it's the real
naughty list oh yeah I always imagine
Santa's like wait a minute Oprah Ellen
cuac oh it's the wrong [__] list all
right Jesus yeah that list is I don't
know I think it's going to come out I
don't think anybody's going to really
care nothing's going to happen but it's
fun to see what's on that list Beyonce
went to Epstein's Island all these all
these fun people so
Bill Clinton Hillary
Clinton the other guy you know yeah look
everybody's a pedophile when you get
down to it yeah sure we got a couple
here any pedophiles
here there you go tackle that
[__]
H everybody's into something my buddy's
into feet he loves women's feet he looks
at feet the way I look at tits but tits
are hard to find feet are everywhere
women's feet flip-flop open toe sandal
he got tits all over the
floor yeah any if you like feet you can
be one of those guys like hey you want
to come into my apartment you got to
take your shoes off that's convenient
huh I can't do that hey you comeing in
here lose the bra [__] let's go come on
rules of rules also everybody loves a
foot massage guy that guy's a hero you
know what I got to do to massage a tit I
got to steal a lap code and be like Oh I
found a
lump that's not sexy
and I've always massage a woman's feet
to get to the better Parts what the
hell's my friend doing he's down there
working she's like why don't you come up
here he's like I'm
done beat guys have got it made oh
abortion abortion bands well here's the
thing abortion is a touchy one I told an
abortion joke last week at a show this
lady got pissed she walked up to me she
goes I've had an abortion that's very
insensitive you shouldn't tell jokes
like that I was like whoa hey sorry I
just told a joke I think what you did
was much worse but stop
good now I like abortions I pay for a
few you know I should have a punch card
at this point but uh no I look at
abortions the same way I look at
reclining my see on airplane I know it
piss a lot of people off but if I got
the option I'm taking
it people say which way do you lean I
say I lean
back oh
yeah Matt Matt R boy he is one sexy
twink isn't he holy [__]
I just want to put my dick on his lips
like a golf ball on a te you know boy
he's got those real dsls doesn't
he I've never even heard his comedy I'm
just staring at his arms and licking my
lips
yeah kill Tony that's a fun show Shan
Gillis he's a fat
[__] say it again
sir hold on I'm getting a real oxycotton
draw off that
guy what the hell was that I know a Fus
said when I hear it
buddy that guy was out in the PE all day
drinking Milwaukee's best and now he's
coming to a show and I can't understand
you sir sound like the water
boy Britney Spears Britney Spears she's
a
Louisiana yeah she just little cut off
so good not poser but um yeah yeah
bretty Spears boy she was under
conservatorship for a while and I don't
know if that's right but I will say when
she got out I saw a vagina within 8
minutes
yeah yeah you know her dam was like I
told you so look at this [__] yeah also
you see that video her with the knives I
was like my God no wonder Justin
Timberlake aborted that kid holy hell
that was a wild video anyone else jerk
off to that all right just
B R Kelly R Kelly there we go now we got
something well I will say he went to
jail at least he had the the good mind
to put out a mix tape that was fun rendy
grinder didn't do that but um AR Kelly
yeah well I was a bed wer as well so
I've also a urinated on a lot of
children
um I went to bed every day I was 13
years old my mattress looked like a
[__] coffee filter all right oh yeah
I ruined a lot of sleepovers folks you
start your around with excuses after
your friend was like what happened here
I was like H geez I must have spilled a
cup of
piss you know har Kelly got 30 years JZ
Lane got 20 so she's got to be thinking
thank God I didn't piss on those kids
huh get 10 more years just for
uring Bruce Jenner New Orleans Bruce
Jenner yes well you know what's funny
when Bruce Jenner turned into Caitlyn
Jenner a lot of women were trying to be
support of and they were like oh she's
so beautiful then I would go well you
kind of look like her and they'd go [__]
you it's fun when you can cut through
the [__] isn't
it Joey Diaz Joey Diaz well I did the
fully loaded tour with Burke rer and I
had to sleep on a bus and it was me in a
bunk Joey Diaz Burke ker Shane Gillis
and big J oerson it was like a [__]
sleep apnea
convention and Joey Diaz is a big fat
drug addict so he sleeps like this [__]
like a
[__] I didn't get a wink of
sleep for two weeks but we had a great
time and he's got some crazy
stories C Worst City i' got I got to go
Boer no no just
kidding you guys are awesome I'm Kevin
har thanks for coming out for I love you
thank you Ranch City go have your night
get it
[Music]
[Applause]
up